foreign
Bruce is with us and Bruce is in Abilene
Texas hi Bruce welcome to the Ramsay
show
I just want to say we love loving all of
you you guys are great thank you Bruce
how can we help well I started a
business in the first couple years I
used a credit card uh all I mean a debit
card all the time and I was having to
break down anywhere from 180 to 220
transactions on my bank statement every
month and it was an accounting nightmare
now here's where I get in trouble I got
five credit cards for my LLC one is for
Sealcoat one's for aggregate one's for
fuel one's for asphalt one's for
supplies there's always money in the
bank and they're all on auto pay and it
has taken all the accounting nightmare
away and I'm
is it possibly is it possible to be an
exception to the little
uh I don't understand why five debit
cards wouldn't do exactly the same thing
well because I've gotten you know free
iPhone I get travel points you know you
didn't tell me about free crap you said
accounting nightmare
it is and you went to five credit cards
why would five debit cards not do the
exact same thing for your accounting
on a debit card could I have five
different ones on one account
yeah they'd have different they'd have
different numbers on them I've got 78 on
one account
Ramsay Solutions runs on debit cards
that goes to show me okay well I I hear
you and I'll make the transition yeah
and here's the thing you can do whatever
you want to do Bruce obviously you're
not going broke from this if you're Auto
paying them and you're not carrying any
balances but what I what I've had to
learn to do was two things and and I I
became fanatical about it and I think
the fanaticism helped me and I and
that's why I'm going to continue selling
it
um
okay uh the the fanatical thing number
one I did was I figured out smart things
that I could automate
and I put Auto I put smart on auto
meaning like Auto uh deduct from my
paycheck going into a 401k Auto deduct
from my checking account in the early
days when they very first started doing
it I was one of the first ones to do it
to pay my utilities always on time and I
always got the discount
okay Auto saving into
kids college coming out of my checking
account Auto saving going into the Roth
IRA out of my checking account every
month so I did smart things on auto that
was the first thing I did I automated
smart and the second thing I did was
anything that looked like a snake it
could bite me I don't play with it
and a credit card that is a snake for
sure
that can bite you even though you've got
your pretty good Snake Charmer you got
them kind of tamed you got them laying
in a you know five distinct buckets and
you've got them on auto pay and all that
kind of stuff you've at least smart did
the auto pay that was a smart move you
know but you still you know you play
with snakes long enough you're gonna get
bit and that's the problem and and so
that's why I just don't have a credit
card and I haven't all these years I
don't want to accidentally end up in
debt
it's just not going to happen I know I
don't owe anyone any money under any
circumstances because I don't have any
tools that I use in the financial world
that can result in debt it's impossible
because I don't sign up
and so I I I stay away from things that
I can accidentally get bit with number
one number two I get Auto I put smart on
auto and those two things take even
because I kept I'm smart enough I kept
trying to outsmart all this crap
and scheming and scamming you know and
it'll get you I think that's a lot of
people's stories I mean most people who
start out using credit cards they don't
think they're going to be the person
thirty thousand dollars in debt no one
does no one no one takes it out it and I
got 10 off at
Macy's and I got the discount no one
ever says and I'm going to end up on
these bozos three grand for 400 years no
one says that no one they just got I got
10 off I got a friend IPhone you know
Bruce I'll make fun of you right okay
whatever right and so that's no one says
oh god look I'm gonna go let's go I'm
intentionally gonna go the average
credit card right now is 22 percent
ouch with inflation the banks helped you
out they went up okay because they
inflated the interest rate from 18 the
average is 22 so no one says I'm going
to intentionally go deeply in debt at 22
and then wonder why I'm broke no one
says that you're right everyone sees the
points they see the bonuses and they
think that they're gonna be the ones
that take advantage of the system they
beat the system and yet the system is
still building skyscrapers they're still
taking people thousands of dollars in
debt yeah
now I do know people that have credit
cards that pay them off every month and
they're not going to cause them to go
bankrupt but you are walking around with
a very small rattlesnake in your pocket
and the small ones bite harder than the
big ones I hear you know so be careful
sneaky just be careful yeah you don't
see them coming they don't they don't
hold back they love they empty all their
venom and so yeah it's it's a problem
and so I just I don't you know I'm gonna
put a home equity line of credit on my
home but we're not going to draw on it
but it'll just be there in case
I need a bass boat in case I want to go
to Disney World in case and yeah you're
in case changes later and then but you
set yourself up you're playing with
snakes and you put a financial thing in
place that allows you to do that and um
another one of these is overdraft
protection
we're going to set up overdraft
protection you're never going to be in
overdraft because it turns into a loan
and guess what
a hundred percent of the time that's
going to turn into a loan
this is what happens with it well if I'm
being wise I don't want to pay any
overdraft fees well here's an idea don't
run your dad gum checking account down
to zero and actually keep up with what
the money's in there
why is this hard
it's not hard but we rationalize our
butts off out there I do I do it too
Bruce has done it I've done it
Christina's done it we've all done it
the question is what's the shortest
fastest best path most proven path to
wealth and it's not that